[Music]
you spent on the similar the ante Bob
I'm sending me away for the summer what
a cliche yeah wait no okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
can you take me home look she gave me
man ok hey yourself
Sophie shot guess who got lucky I can't
get around my mind
[Music]
what would you say if I told you I
wanted to start so we what's this one
that's a zip more people plot these my
life will be a lot of media we should
sell more of those the problem is we're
dealing dime bags teenagers we need
customers who buy in bulk you didn't
know how to use a bomb and now you're
trying to tell me how to flip week I
have something even looking for you know
you're not cops
gosh a good question cops can't do that
sit down give me more money to be the
rest I've ever seen shady right lazy
sweetheart
play something celebratory happens every
song Munir so heavy campaign
night's turn long sleepless when you are
cooler times you know where it is it's
gonna tear you apart can't hold on
everything I think some things here and
I hope you're gonna bang her
[Music]